[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to gamespot's
coverage of summer game fest 2022. i'm
here with gamespot's own phil hornshaw
and you just played lego brawls did it's
actually been out of mobile for a while
though right but you played the the ps5
version yeah so yeah this is the bigger
port uh over the ps5
and yeah it's pretty cool it's a four on
four like
compat it's it's sort of similar to a
fighting game like a smash brothers but
the idea is a little more cooperative a
lot of the time so you're like on a team
of four against another team of four
doing things like capturing a control
point stuff like that okay so you
mentioned smash brothers there and i
think that's what everyone has in their
head that this is basically the lego
version of smash brothers so
in what way is it like smash brothers so
it's a fairly light combat platform race
game right yeah it's mostly uh like a
pretty chill melee game you know you've
got like a standard weapon that you
carry around it could be a sword or a
plunger or you know any of a half dozen
other or a million actually much more
like a million other lego things but
they all just kind of bash people um
and then you are able to find items like
you would in smash brothers or like item
boxes and you can open those up and they
give you one of three i think different
tiers of item which you set ahead of
time as part of your loadout so you've
got like a light item that might be like
a lasso you could use to like
freeze up another player and pummel them
for a minute um or you might get like a
medium one which was uh for me it was
like a a food truck that shot sausages
and could run people over okay and then
your third one is uh
something even more powerful these all
have armor too if it's like vehicles
that have like their own health bar and
then the third one i got was a dragon
who could fly and shoot fireballs and
they're like you know limited time you
only get them for a few seconds they can
get bashed on and you could lose them um
but that's kind of the gist is that
you're trying to get these items to sort
of overwhelm the other team for a second
but it's very back and forth kind of
chaos so it's like an assist in smash
bros i'm finding it very hard to picture
the hot dog truck so hopefully we have
footage that's going over this as we
speak
you know it looks like if you built a
truck out of lego it's
what it looks like but it shoots
sausages i don't know it's weird it's
all stuff from a bunch of different lego
sets uh they've got you know years and
years of lego stuff in here like ninjago
jurassic park but then more generic
stuff the it's like the lego ip like
castle
and the way it works is you like as
you're playing alone you pick a theme
that you want to work on of like a lego
set and then as you play you're kind of
leveling up
and unlocking more of that stuff and
it's all custom customization and like a
few of those loadout
loadout items sorry that you can use and
bring into battle but most of it is just
like cosmetic stuff to
kind of go crazy and make your little
guy for when you get into a fight and
you know make him a knight with clown
hair and
his space suit and all kinds of stuff
from what he described this does sound
like you know like all of the recent
lego games in which basically it's just
like a big
genre mash-up of you know all of the
warner brothers properties so
is that the same thing there like
because i think you mentioned what a
million customizations like what they're
claiming no i it just seemed like a
whole whole ton of them um and like just
all kinds of stuff that you might find
in various lego sets you know like you
could fight people with the sword or
like alien stuff or a mop you know all
kinds of stuff like that and it and like
i mentioned the truck but there are a
bunch of other things too and they
things that might not seem like weapons
necessarily you know and but they're fun
to bring into the battlefield and just
kind of
rage around for a minute and then they
go away and so you've got it's a lot of
scrambling around trying to find your
next thing or bash people when you've
got a second you know with your whatever
you're carrying and what sort of ips did
they throw into this one because yeah
the lego games had all these really
amazing ips um so i saw jurassic park
for sure and there's a lot of jurassic
park stuff arranging that entire series
from the original movie to the the
latest uh jurassic world movies um
ninjago stuff a lot of that as well i
don't know what else i didn't see any
like harry potter or anything else uh
like that so it doesn't seem like it's
too expensive on ip it's more i think
focused on
the variety of cool
weird lego stuff that's not necessarily
tied to maybe another franchise or
something like that like off camera you
did mention to me the open shirt ian
malcolm
from jurassic park yeah
he's there also uh like john hammond and
you could bash people with his like
amber walking stick and stuff like that
so look one thing i want to go back to
like you mentioned at the start that
this is a lot more cooperative in nature
so explain that a little bit more so uh
there's like a
fighting the ai side which is
cooperative and you're like four on four
teams and so you're in a big map of a
very like might be a volcano kind of
place or a ghost-filled haunted house
and running around these places are
little control points like you might see
in halo or gears of war and your idea is
that you want to take control of that
bash everybody else off of it hold that
down that's how you score points so it's
four on four in those cases and i think
you can play that uh maybe online with
other people and cooperate that way when
we played couch co-op that was a more
smash brothers-like four-player
free-for-all type fight and it removed
the control points and we were just
hitting each other um and running around
like picking up items and the items were
themed on the location
so they were very they were specific
like a crossbow that like made people
blow up in the
in the
the lava level which also had rising
lava and going up and down and stuff
like that again like you might see in a
smash brothers level
um yeah so it's it's
those two kinds of different experiences
it seems like but it's
you can do the more team-based fighting
or you can just go nuts like you would
expect to in a couch co-op game and do
you know that sort of chaos and i guess
we we keep mentioning the the customized
customization options in this game um
but as you mentioned it's all purely
cosmetic though right or do you stick
with a certain lego set and and build up
that set or is it just mainly to unlock
stuff and to look cool it seems like
it's too unlocked stuff to look cool and
you can look very cool what that was the
the thing that might have been the most
fun was creating your little guy to take
into a battle i made like a weird clown
with a cowboy uh like cowboy clothes and
he had a horse
um on his chest like it was if he was
writing it you know but he was actually
just wearing it yeah um you they also
mentioned that you could like you know
that ian malcolm with his shirt open you
could take his head toss it on a
different body you can mix and match all
that stuff so the more you're unlocking
the more options you're getting to
making something weird and crazy
and
uh like our jordan had a character with
pom-poms and like a face tattoo and he
looked like a gnarly pirate but he was
also a cheerleader and stuff like that
and it's uh there are a lot of options
there and it seems like it like like i
said it pulls from the sort of like
generic uh lego world as well as the ip
driven one so there are
a lot of like weird ways you can
customize it um and find like avenues
you wouldn't expect like like i said
with the clown was really my favorite
for sure
but phil that's concerning that a clown
like with cowboy clothes and a horse
coming out of his chest yeah sounds more
like a horror movie but this this
this definitely is more a
family-focused game right so it's not
really a core fighter and any sense of
the word i mean like your main attack is
a melee um you just have this like
everybody starts with a sword or a sword
like weapon mop or whatever and you're
just hitting people with that when you
don't have another item right so it's
not like you're doing combos it's not
like you're doing smash attacks it is a
much more like chill relaxed
uh sort of fighter it's more about
positioning a lot of platforming around
um you know tricking people and falling
into lava that sort of thing
and then when you do get those items
that's your chance to kind of like
rampage a little bit but you know you
uh for when you're facing that sort of
thing you want to get out of the way
you're trying to get out of the over to
the other side of the level or
out think how you can avoid that for the
limited time that it's going to be
chasing you around so yeah it's like
it's not going to go super high skill
ceiling or anything like that but there
is enough
uh sort of craziness going on that it's
pretty engaging anybody can i think pick
it up and have fun with it but you can
still like i still got beat by our guy
dave so
like
you know like there's definitely
something to it there's a competitive
element for sure but couch hijinks
family exactly friends okay uh phil do
we know when uh this game is coming out
and i know you played ps5 do we know the
other platforms that's coming out i
believe we have xbox switch and i want
to say pc and i think it's this month
all right thank you very much for that
phil that was our look at lego brawls
for more on summer game fest keep
itching the game spot
[Music]
you